bien ahora vamos a tomar un clip grande
y utilizarlo para hacer las monturas de
los motores lo primero que necesitamos
hacer es enderezar el clip lo más que se
pueda así que vamos a remover todos los
pliegues y protuberancias en el clip lo
mejor que podamos con nuestras manos y
una vez que hayamos eliminado casi todos
los pliegues vamos a tomar nuestras
pinzas de punta y vamos a quitar el
resto de ellos para tener el clip lo más
recto posible
así que una vez que tengamos el clip
enderezado vamos a doblarlo a un ángulo
de 90 grados a modo que se ajuste
perfectamente contra los interruptores
una vez que esté en su lugar tomaremos
nuestro pulgar y vamos a mantenerlo
contra el clip sólo lo doblamos y
estamos usando nuestro soporte de
baterías como herramienta de modelado y
lo estamos doblando hacia abajo primero
y también un poco hacia adelante después
así que de nuevo vamos a poner nuestro
pulgar en el borde y después lo doblamos
hacia abajo y luego un poco hacia
adelante y la razón por la cual hacemos
esto es porque nos permitirá ajustar de
manera precisa los motores
podríamos solamente pegarlos con silicón
caliente a un costado del soporte de
baterías pero tal vez los motores no
estarían en un ángulo adecuado que nos
agrade o podrían estar a diferentes
ángulos y así no seríamos capaces de
corregirlos así que este paso extra nos
ayudará
y básicamente nos permitirá ahorrar
tiempo en cualquier caso sólo estamos
haciendo una segunda revisión y
asegurarnos de que todo encaja y vamos a
asegurarnos también de que los contactos
dorados del motor están hacia afuera y
hacia arriba así que vamos a pegar el
clip al otro lado del motor con silicón
caliente ahora lo que hice justo ahorita
también fue poner el motor en el clip y
básicamente trate de evaluar qué tan
largo necesitaba estar así que está
cerca de tres cuartos de pulgada de
largo y después doblaremos un pequeño
ángulo bastante pronunciado hasta el
final del clip y bueno yo sé que es un
poco difícil de tener control sobre él
así que vamos a cortar el otro del mismo
largo muy bien allá vamos y bueno puedes
usar unas pinzas de corte o algunas
veces las piezas de punta así tendrán
una herramienta de corte incorporada a
ellas así que queremos sacar sólo un
poco el clip en un ángulo y con eso los
motores van a fijarse a ese ángulo por
lo tanto queremos que salgan a no ser
aproximadamente a un ángulo de 45 grados
no tiene que ser perfecto porque
nuevamente podemos ajustarlos después
ahora bien tenemos un clip en nuestro
motor y queremos estar seguros de que el
clip sostiene el motor en su lugar y
para poder hacerlo solo voy a volver a
ponerlo aquí y tratar de asegurarme de
que todo encaje y vamos a comprobar que
tenemos suficiente clip en la parte
posterior del motor y que tiene la
longitud adecuada un poco para tener una
percepción de como el motor
en este interruptor cada uno de éstos
van a ser ligeramente diferentes porque
ya saben todo el mundo es diferente y
por lo tanto lo van a crear de una
manera diferente ligeramente diferente
pero una vez que tengamos nuestro clip
en el motor y de hecho este está de lujo
porque parece que tenemos la longitud
adecuada con el fin de que el motor no
esté girando alrededor del clip entonces
vamos a doblarlo a un ángulo de 90
grados y bueno usando las pinzas de
punta solo al final para poder poner un
pequeño ángulo pronunciado y eso va a
sostener el motor y además va a
mantenerlo de que no esté girando
alrededor del clip
así que pondremos el clip de vuelta y
vamos a asegurarnos de que el motor esté
en el ángulo al que queremos de hecho no
no es exactamente el ángulo adecuado así
que lo que haremos será tomar las pinzas
de punta y doblarlo un poco y
asegurarnos de que el motor está
alineado a los largos del soporte de
batería
y de nuevo esto requiere un poco de
ajuste
pero una vez que lo haces bien funciona
bastante bien
así que ahí vamos esto está bien y de
nuevo no debe de quedar perfecto una vez
que el motor esté colocado si por alguna
razón no encaja bien siempre puedes
tomar el silicón caliente y quitarlo
despegarlo e intentar de nuevo además
tenemos un clip extra en el equipo en
caso de que lo necesitemos siempre
recomiendo cuando armen sus equipos de
herramientas que tengan un clip extra
porque los vamos a estar utilizando así
van a tener un clip de más y si por
alguna razón no sale bien la primera vez
entonces puedes cambiarlo ahora sí vamos
a ponerle el silicón caliente y lo que
queremos es colocar cerca de un octavo
de pulgada de grosor de silicón caliente
y extenderlo uniformemente para así
asegurarnos de que el clip está
completamente cubierto tomará un poco de
tiempo para que se seque esto pero eso
si vas a poder distinguir que está seco
cuando cambias de color transparente a
un color lechoso bien ahora ya está seco
y el motor lo tenemos aquí y debes estar
seguro de que el silicón
está completamente frío antes de que
ajustes a detalle porque de otra manera
el clip puede salirse del silicón y
tendrás que hacerlo todo de nuevo
y vamos a doblar este lado de la misma
forma poniéndole un pequeño ángulo
pronunciado y ahora vamos a tomar
nuestro motor y vamos a alinearlo justo
como lo hicimos del otro lado y le
daremos vuelta
es importante recordar que los contactos
del motor dos de color dorado o latón
esos deben de sobresalir y que no estén
en el lado donde vas a pegar el tip
ahora vamos a seguir adelante y poner
eso aquí hay que mantener esto en la
orientación correcta así va a permanecer
en su lugar y el silicón caliente estará
rodeando por completo el clip ten
cuidado es fácil que se muevan y que no
se sostenga muy bien ok el silicon ya se
ha enfriado y puedes notarlo porque de
nuevo tiene este color lechoso y ahora
vamos a hacer algunos ajustes a detalle
al clip para asegurarnos de que este
montaje del motor va a encajar alrededor
del soporte de baterías además como el
silicon tiene un grosor grande este
tenderá a empujar los motores y algunas
veces necesitaremos hacer algunos
ajustes a este mismo clip así que vamos
a usar nuestras pizzas de punta para
asegurarnos de que los motores están
alineados de la manera que queremos pues
lo estamos doblando a uno
a grados y en el clip tenemos muy poco
espacio para poder ajustar y asegurarnos
de que los motores encajen perfectamente
así que con estas pinzas lo que vamos a
hacer es ajustar el clip porque tenemos
muy poco espacio y quiero que nos
aseguremos de que los motores encajen
perfectamente